you know if you put me and RuPaul beside
each other we make the number-10 think
about it Eureka O'Hara
back back back again we didn't know you
would officially be back for Season ten
oh I know and I wasn't sure either but
you know it was a long journey it was
exciting the doctors finally released me
after I threatened to blow up their home
so here did you question it all coming
back I did question actually the
craziest thing is right after season 9
started airing my mother got sick with
throat cancer so weirdly I didn't
question coming back over my injury at
question coming back over my family and
my mom but she reminded me she said hey
get your big pants on get over there and
do your thing make it to the end try to
be your best honey cuz you need to
remind me why I love you and believe in
you so much so
she's the amazing Amazon how is she
doing now she's doing pretty good she's
in a neutral place I'm not completely in
remission but we're looking at she's
doing the F in a nice let's talk about
your up and up on season 10 we have so
much season left to watch oh my gosh
yeah how was season 10 different from
season 9 that's a completely different
group of girls right one two its season
ten so they are pulling out all the
stops this season the challenges are
harder than ever they're bringing back a
few challenges that people are gonna be
really excited about that are iconic
moments from past seasons we've got the
drama the personalities the costumes on
the runway it's it's an incredible
season season 9 was a little calmer I
think and a little more sisterly and now
we've grown to be sisters the honey and
competition we were vicious [ __ ]
they'll be ready I am America's next
drag superstar girl back when you walked
back into that workroom even sized up
all the other Queens that were there who
did you clock as your biggest
competition
I wasn't sure because like I said
there's so many huge personalities I
think I was a little alarmed by
Monique's personality Asia was really
good funny and talking to miss crackers
really funny the Vixen came in ready to
fight
I know mayhem Miller literally a staple
of Valley communities so of course she's
gonna be incredible aquaria has the most
in satiable social media following and
reputation so of course she's gonna
bring looks she's super smart
understands drag race more than anyone
right now so there's a lot of people
that seem like competition
so for me I'm just like how can I cut 13
other girls icky Leo's tendons is there
a valentina in the bunch this season oh
yeah I'm not gonna tell you who I'm on
the child figure that out okay yeah why
don't y'all figure that out I don't
agree with that kind of behavior do you
feel like these other Queens we're ready
to come for you a little bit because you
had competed before what was that like
oh god yeah I think some of the girls
are holding me to maybe some moments
that happened in season nine okay I'm
very gone please this is typical Eureka
you know obviously me and Trinity didn't
get along the best for the good morning
[ __ ] challenge and they were afraid
I'd raise my hand out of my gas and
follow the rules that we sat in place
but you know I am talking if I am loud I
am annoying it's just who I am and I
love every bit of it
- Rico why dareka talks a lot luckily it
makes great TVs does miss charlie hide
once told you could you shut up a second
that will eat you right now oh come here
on a team phone home says phone huh I
have et phone alright if you had to sum
up the season it with just one word one
word for the whole season
I'm just now it's a tan tan-tan status -
yes I give it a 10
now have you ever seen bar C blue a team
I can see I gave it a dan dan dan dan
thank you so much Eureka good luck with
the rest of season 10 I hope we see you
at the end with a crown with a crown or
not as long as I get a good path and God
puts me in right now f that let's see
wheel the crown let's see her with a
karate you know if you put me and RuPaul
beside each other we make the number 10
think about it
and what better way to end season 10
there we go thank you so much
[Music]